Поїхали!
Це відкрите тренування в центрі Бонна.
Ось так прийти позайматись у парк може будь-хто.
Тут, аби було добре чути, гучно інструктує тренерка.
Угору... і знову вниз.
Щоб ніхто не розслаблявся - мотивує.
І назад... І ще два рази для мене.
По п'ятницях на занятті з різних видів вправ,
так званого буткемпу, зокрема і бігають ...
...і качають прес.
Українка Владлена мешкає в Бонні вже майже рік -
навчається в місцевому університеті, але на такому занятті вперше.
Зізнається: вправи даються нелегко.
Поки що мені трохи важко, тому що я не дуже,
мабуть, спортивна, не дуже часто це роблю,
але це весело.
Тренування на свіжому повітрі відбуваються по буднях -
з травня й аж до кінця вересня - поки тепло.
Вони так і називаються "Спорт у парку".
Моніка ходить сюди вже кілька тижнів.
Це нелегке тренування,
це схоже на справжній виклик,
але наприкінці ти почуваєшся дуже щасливим.
Якщо силові навантаження не для вас, ви можете прийти в інший день.
Наприклад, на йогу в понеділок. Реєструватись непотрібно й оплачувати тренування теж.
Ініціатива для тих, хто хоче позайматись, абсолютно безкоштовна.
Таке рішення ухвалили в міській адміністрації,
аби залучити якомога більше людей до занять.
Кажуть: щоб містяни були здоровими.
Для цього чиновники найняли компанію-організатора,
яка шукає спортивні клуби, що надають тренерів.
Коучі проводять заняття одночасно у чотирьох парках міста,
аби всім було зручно й близько добиратись.
Щодня в нас інший тренінг і ви можете побачити, що вам подобається найбільше.
Зокрема, йдеться ще про пілатес, інтенсивне тренування та бойове мистецтво.
За 4 місяці таких занять місто викладає в перерахунку з євро -
понад 700 тисяч гривень.
Місто платить 25 тисяч євро,
також є приватні партнери, які оплачують маркетинг
та замовляють одяг для тренерів.
Ця програма триває вже 4-ий рік.
За словами організатора тренувань, розпочинати було складно.
Було важко почати, але соціальні мережі допомогли.
Ти робиш кілька світлин, публікуєш їх -
- і так починається кампанія.
З першого року спортом в парку загалом займаються
приблизно 20 тисяч людей.
Нині, якщо гарна погода, на одне таке заняття приходить
від ста до двохсот людей.
Двадцятисемирічний Макс ходить сюди вже третє літо поспіль.
Для нього заняття вкрай важливі.
У мене є проблеми з ногами. Це допомагає мені їх розтягувати.
А хтось використовує це, як можливість безкоштовно потренуватись
або просто відпочити після робочого дня.